probably the granddaddy of all of these
idea pathogens would be
postmodernism because postmodernism if
you'd like
is the negation of the scientific method
it's the negation that there is
a truth with capital t that is out there
to be discovered
says that there's only subjective truth
everybody is bound by their biases by
their subjectivity there are no
objective truths everything is
subjective
it has been a very long time coming but
i'm finally joined here by the man
behind the sad truth the godfather
himself
so good to have you here thank you so
much for having me chris good to be with
you
pleasure burning question that obviously
everyone has come here
to work out is adele's hairstyle
problematic
deeply problematic i i didn't know that
she was
a mixture of himmler and hitler but
apparently she is by the way for those
of you who don't know this about a few
years ago
i did a couple of sad truths the one sad
truth was where i gave temporary
clearance to anyone who wanted to eat
lebanese food
i gave him a 24-hour period because i'm
lebanese
i'm entitled to speak on behalf of all
lebanese and so i gave a culinary
clearance for 24 hours
and then i asked for everyone to take a
photo of their
passports so that they can give me
clearance in whatever they want to give
me clearance in so for example
a portuguese person would write and say
my name is jose whatever rodriguez
and i give you clearance to eat
portuguese
spicy chicken so you should go check it
out because it shows you that most
people are still
sane and make fun of this stupidity so
that's like a an
iou reciprocal altruism thing that
you've got going on here
i eat your food you eat my food but you
can only eat it once
and then it's like you've got a track
and trace thing going on as well
which exactly covid so we're going to
talk about your new book parasitic mind
but before we do could you give us a bit
of an overview of your background as an
academic
why do you have a license to talk about
this subject sure
uh so i have been a professor for 26
years
uh my main area of scientific research
although i'm someone who's
a true polymath i'm all over the place
uh i truly believe in
interdisciplinarity
but my main claim to fame if you'd like
in academia is that i founded the field
of evolutionary consumption which is
basically
applying evolutionary biology and
evolutionary psychology
to study our consumatory nature so just
to give you one quick example it would
be
here's one how do our hormones affect
our behaviors as consumers for example
when men engage in conspicuous
consumption
what happens to their testosterone
levels when women are going through the
various stages of their menstrual cycles
how what kinds of foods do they eat how
do they dress does that vary across the
menstrual cycle so i look at the
biological underpinnings of our
consuming instinct if you'd like and as
part of being an evolutionary slash
consumer psychologist i've always been
interested in inter-species comparisons
this is a field called comparative
psychology so
oftentimes if you want to make the
argument that some behavior is an
evolutionary behavior within the human
context
you will study cognition and other
species to make the link because they
are our evolutionary cousins
and so as a result of my if you like my
openness
to studying other animals i noticed that
there was a field called
neuroparasitology which is the study of
how
parasites can infect the brains
of a whole host of hosts so for example
toxoplasma gandhi is a parasite that
affects the brains of
mice and when they are infected with
this brain worm they lose their
innate fear of cats they become sexually
attracted to the urine of the cat which
is not a good thing for a mouse to to be
attracted to
and so i took this principle from animal
uh
context and i argued that
humans suffer not only from actual brain
worms
in the same way that the mouse does but
we suffer from another
class of idea pathogens and those are
actual ideas
that are parasitic and of course your
original question is
what allows me to make those you know
arguments well having lived in the
ecosystem of
academia for the past 26 years i can
promise you
that all of the most idiotic ideas all
stem from academia
does that give you a good answer
absolutely yeah you are patient zero for
this
so what zero what's an infectious idea
right so uh probably the granddaddy of
all of these
idea pathogens would be postmodernism
because
postmodernism if you'd like is the
negation
of the scientific method it's the
negation that there is
a truth with capital t that is out there
to be discovered
now i should always i always like to
preface that scientists do have
epistemic humility so we recognize that
what is true today
might become untrue tomorrow in light of
new evidence but at any given point
we do operate under the premise that
there is a truth out there to be
discovered there is for example
a universal human nature as an
evolutionary psychologist i want to
study that there is
certain recurring patterns of how women
respond to their ovulatory cycles
postmodernism completely blows up this
edifice of reason because it says that
there's only subjective truth everybody
is bound by their biases by their
subjectivity there are no objective
truths
everything is subjective and so there's
a a now famous story that i
recount which for some of your viewers
who might not be familiar with my work
it's maybe worth repeating
i once had a chat with a postmodernist
radical feminist and cultural
anthropologist so kind of the holy
trinity of [ __ ]
wow that's the dark triad isn't it that
is the dark triad right
and so she uh i had gone out to dinner
with
uh my wife my doctoral student who had
just
defended his dissertation and she was
this woman was his date for the evening
and he had warned me that this person
you know
is infected with these parasites
although he didn't use those words
uh and so he was kind of imploring me to
be on my best behavior so we can have a
good time
uh because we were out to celebrate his
accomplishment of having finished his
phd to which i said yes of course
i'll be on my best behavior which of
course was [ __ ] uh
and so and so halfway through the the
dinner or whatever it was
i said to her so i hear you're a
postmodernist uh yes yes i am
uh so there are no universal truths
absolutely not so do you mind if i maybe
offer you some universal truths
and then you can tell me how you think i
might be wrong she said yes go ahead go
for it
say well is it a universal truth that
within the human species
only women bear children is that not a
truth
can we can we hang our hat on this one
she says absolutely not
oh no how so well there is a
tribe of some island in japan where
within the
folkloric realm within the spiritual
realm it is the men who bear
children so by you restricting the
conversation
of bearing children to the physical
realm this is how you keep us
pregnant and barefoot in the kitchen
after
i am resuscitated with an ambulance from
the stupidity of her point
uh i then say okay maybe i shouldn't ask
you something as controversial as
you know bearing children maybe that's
just too corrosive of a topic
so let's do something a bit less
sensitive
is it true since time immemorial that
within the vantage of earth
sailors have relied on the premise that
the sun rises in the east and sets in
the west is that not a universal truth
and then here she uses a sub form of
post-modernism called deconstructionism
language creates reality
so she says well what do you mean by
east and west those are just
arbitrary labels and what do you mean by
the sun
that which you call the sun i call
dancing hyena
to which i retorted while the dancing
hyena rises in the east and sets in the
west
i put on dancing hyena lotion when i go
to the caribbean so i don't get dancing
hyena
burn to which she said i don't play
those label games
now that was an incredibly uh
prescient story if you'd like because
this happened in 2002
and today you can get cancelled for
saying that only women bear children you
can get
fired for saying that there are two
sexes you can get
fired for saying that only women
menstruate
and so this is what happens when in this
case the granddaddy of idea pathogens
takes over
academia up is down left is right there
are no truths
it does seem like post-modernism is the
source code
that's underwritten everything and then
what you've got on top of that are some
apps
so very nice nice way of putting it yes
yeah so you have the particular
operating system that's
post modernism and then you have give us
some of the apps what are some of the
apps that people have downloaded onto
their social justice phone
sure so so for example anything with the
trans
prefix becomes an instantiation of it's
my
truth there is no truth right so there
is transgender now by the way when i say
this that doesn't mean that i'm negating
the fact that there is such a thing as
transgender people and there is such a
thing as we should not
we should not be bigoted against them
and they should live free of bigotry so
one doesn't imply the other but for
example when
in the pursuit of transactivism you
negate biological realities that the
average three day old
newborn pigeon knows then that becomes a
problem
right so you have to be able to chew and
walk at the same time i could fully
i could be fully liberal and supportive
of transgender
rights while also saying look if you're
270 pounds and six foot four
and suddenly you call yourself a woman
no you can't
compete against biological women and it
doesn't make you a transphobe
my my very young children look at this
quizzically and they don't understand it
are they transphobes are they hitler's
so so that would be one example radical
feminism is another
perfect manifestation of this right in
the pursuit of equality under the law
which we should all support that doesn't
mean that we reject that there are
innate sex differences but most radical
feminists
think that by giving leeway to the
possibility that men and women might be
different
different this opens the door to
maintaining the sexist patriarchal
status quo
no we can recognize that men and women
are equal under the law and there
shouldn't be any institutional bigotry
while also recognizing that there is
such a thing called sexual selection
darwin which basically says that we have
evolved many things similarly
but many things differently precisely
because we are a sexually reproducing
species
so these would be a few examples you
want me to give you more or no i think
we've got we've got some good ones there
it seems to me that the
the pernicious thing about these ideas
is that they've got a kernel of truth
right
and is that the the delivery mechanism
is that the delivery mechanism of the
parasite so give give me an example
of how rejecting that only women
could menstruate could have a kernel of
children so for instance with regards to
the trans rights we want to ensure that
people who are transgender are treated
fairly equally in society with radical
feminism
everyone believes that women perhaps in
the past there were some particular
prejudices that they had to battle
against we had a
jet movement those are fairly objective
you couldn't vote you couldn't do
x y and z but it's when that gets turned
up to
111
sorry that's it just that there's
kernels of truth
most of which appear to be kind of
archaically grandfathered in
yeah i would say that they're different
objectives it's not that
the objective of seeking social justice
in the true sense of the term not in the
pejorative social justice warriors
that is something that we should all
seek if we are you know rational liberal
you know good-hearted people in the
pursuit of that objective
we never murder truth we never
rape truth that's the problem is that
what they do is they conflate the
pursuit of social justice
with a consequentialist ethic right
which basically says
it doesn't matter if i murder and rape
truth
in the service of this more laudable
goal
called social justice no as a purist
i'm a true classical liberal
person i believe in the rights of
transgender people
but without sacrificing a millimeter
of my commitment to truth to science to
logic
the common sense to rationality so
that's why i separate these
these two things why the parasite
analogy
so the parasite analogy is exactly as i
said stemming from the
neuroparasitology literature which
demonstrates that
you know it's almost science fiction
right you can have this parasite
now by the way the reason why i say
neuro parasitology because parasites
can take hold in different parts of your
body right so you can have a tapeworm
that's in your gut right so
neuroparasites are
ones that seek the brain because as part
of their reproductive cycle this is
where they
have to kind of go so there's a parasite
that will infect the brains of certain
insects causing these insects who are
otherwise very
waterphobic to jump into the water
as if they're kind of committing hara
you know kamikaze thing
they hate the water because the parasite
needs the water to then
complete its reductive cycle so it is
rewiring your circuitry
to its benefit well idea pathogens are
doing the exact same thing right
they can take a otherwise supposedly
functioning human being
and then you can have these idiotic
ideas infect your brain
so that you could become a mush of
[ __ ] so that you
instead of instead of jumping into the
the water as the insect does
you now jump off the abyss of infinite
lunacy right
so uh you know all borders are racists
well there is this thing called
countries and nations
and countries have borders and last i
checked
it wasn't only the nazis who were
condoning
borders but i can walk with you on
university campuses
where that is the official position
borders are
a form of white supremacy so when people
start saying things that are so such
departures from common sense then the
parasitology analogy is really quite an
apt one
with parasites you have no control over
i'm gonna guess it's not due to will
that the mice go and become attracted to
the cats they're not thinking i fancy
about being ah that's kind of it's kind
of sexy but a bit of
cat wii over the far side that it's
they're compelled to do it
right this is semantic right this is
this is an idea this is there's an
abstraction to this
there must also be an ability
yeah well this is both
before we get to how can we protect
people how can people protect themselves
how can you get the parasite out of
yourself that's a great question so
it really it so anything that i'm going
to say in answering that question
how do we how do we inoculate ourselves
against this how do we vaccinate
ourselves i guess if we're already
parasitized how do we cure ourselves
that rests on one single
you know a priory tenet and that is that
you are
at least open to
my evidence right so so if you just go
la la la la la my ears and i'm not going
to listen
then there's absolutely you're
impenetrable there's no way for me it's
kind of like saying
you you'd like to benefit from the
vaccine but you're too scared of the
needle
and therefore you i can't give you that
right
so so once we agree that you are
open to the vaccine then here is how
there are several things that we can do
but let me discuss the
the the biggest one so there is a thing
in chapter seven of my book which i call
normal logical networks of cumulative
evidence
now this originally comes from my work
in evolutionary psychology actually
which i now apply to this context so
homological networks of cumulative
evidence is the idea that if i'm trying
to convince you
of an explanation let's say a scientific
explanation
i have to start thinking this way what
would be the data
that i would need to show you that
becomes so
unassailable that even the most dogged
the tractor will be drowned in a sea of
evidence right
now as someone you're in britain correct
correct
right so charles darwin if you'd like is
perhaps the most famous example of
someone who was thinking
synthetically in this way synthetically
meaning putting a whole bunch of stuff
together
creating conciliance unity of knowledge
now he didn't use the term nomological
networks of cumulative evidence but
that's exactly what he was doing because
in demonstrating that his theory of
natural selection
was vertical was correct what did he do
he assiduously over many decades
collected data
from an incredible number of sources
from paleontology from animal husbandry
from embryology from comparative anatomy
from geology and each of these small
pieces of the puzzle once you put the
whole thing together
made it impossible for you to argue
against it despite the fact that 150
years later people are still trying to
falsify it
without being able to right and so i
take this
mindset and i formalize it in this thing
called neurological networks of
chemotherapy evidence
maybe if i give you a specific example
it will help
explain okay so let's suppose i want to
show i want to prove to you
that toy preferences are not due to
social construction
in other words it's not just mommy and
daddy are sexist pigs
and they teach little johnny to play
with the truck and little linda to play
you know with the doll right in other
words there is something beyond the
social constructivist argument
how would i go about demonstrating this
to you so now what i'm going to do
is i'm going to say can i get data from
different cultures
different time periods different
paradigms different disciplines
different methodologies all of which
point to the same incontrovertible
final conclusion well so i'll just do a
few okay
well i can look at children who are in
the
pre-socialization stage of their
cognitive development
meaning they're too young to have been
socialized they're
three months old they're six months old
and i could study
their sex specific toy preferences now
you might say well how would you elicit
their preference
they can't speak yet they're three or
six months old well you can do it
through eye gaze you could do it through
how they
what do they go towards and what you
show
is that children who are in the
pre-socialization cognitive
developmental stage
are already exhibiting the sex-specific
toy preferences that we then see in
later children
now if i already stopped there i'm
already giving you evidence
that is slowly you know making the cot
you know the nail in the coffin but i'm
gonna give you a lot more okay
if you take little girls who suffer from
congenital adrenal hyperplasia
which is an endocrinological disorder
that
masculinizes their morphology and
masculinizes
their behavior so little girls who
suffer from this disorder
are more boy-like and we take this
group of little girls and look at their
toy preferences
what do you think happens to their toy
preferences they are reversed they're
exactly like those of boys
so now i've given you two data sets i've
given you data sets from developmental
psychology and i've now given you data
from
pediatrics from pediatric endocrinology
now already the social constructivist
thing should be in the dustbin of
[ __ ] history right
but let's go on i could look at other
species
vervet monkeys rhesus monkeys
chimpanzees
to see whether the infants in those
species exhibit the same
sex specificity and toy preferences and
guess what my man
they do well you'd have to argue that
mama vervet monkey and papa vervet
monkey
are prone to the same patriarchal sexist
influences that we see in humans right
so now i've given you if you like three
boxes of the
nomological network bit by bit i will
drown you in evidence
so that it becomes very difficult for
you to stick to your position
so what i try to then argue to people
that
epistemology that i just described need
not only apply to scientific arguments
or to
evolutionary based arguments it could
apply to
any phenomenon that has a lot of
contentious debate around it so
the example that i give in the book the
sort of the final example in chapter
seven is
is islam a peaceful religion or not
now i don't need to get into hysteria i
don't need to listen to noble prophet
barack obama telling me that it is
peaceful or not
i simply need to build an homological
network and if that neurological network
says that islam is peaceful
then we've proven that it's peaceful if
it says otherwise
then we've proven otherwise so i don't
need hysteria
i don't need emotionality i don't need
to trigger my affective system
i simply go where the data tells me to
go
does that give you a good sense of how
to get vaccinated against bs it does
but is that an effort that people have
to do individually so have i got to go
and do this literature review where i
scour the internet
and i look at this stuff and is that a
veritable source and so on and so forth
so that's a great question in a sense
it's a slightly
less extreme version of putting my ears
in my right because what you're saying
is okay even if i don't
even if i'm open to listening to you do
i have the cognitive
uh desire also more than that
the um effort for me to protect myself
potentially from one of these ideas
is that on me to go out and
search for this much stuff or is uh is
there some platform and there's some
particular voices
have you got a book yes so so one of the
one of the projects that i'm currently
working on and i just published an
academic
paper on exactly that so one of the
ideas that i have is to
have something akin to a wikipedia
platform
where what is it it's true this is not a
joke this is real i know it's not a joke
but it's funny
i've got a question i've got a question
coming up that that this relates to so
i'm going to let you go and then i'm
going to give you i'm going to give you
the truth
so but now what i'm going to say is
specific only to evolutionary psychology
so it's not to any debate
so one of the one of the things that i
find most
galling when imbeciles argue against
evolutionary psychology
sorry i don't mean to say imbeciles
that's not diplomatic
people with a differing opinion also
known as
lobotomized idiots right so
they will say things like well you know
bro evolutionary psychology is
pseudoscience
uh yeah you're a [ __ ] the mind
didn't come from magic it didn't arise
through
a magical cultural process culture
exists in its form
because of biology not instead of
biology socialization matters
but socialization is not something in
lieu of biology
it's because of biology so unless you
unless you think that everything in our
body is due to evolution
short of the organ that most defines our
personhood this thing called the human
mind
then there is no such thing as
evolutionary psychology is pseudoscience
now you can argue
that this particular study in
evolutionary psychology did not meet the
evidentiary threshold that i like
for me to be convinced but that's also
true when astrophysicists are deciding
whether the universe is expanding or
contracting
so the fact that you we may debate about
specifics and evolutionary theory or
evolutionary psychology
doesn't imply that the epistemological
exercise of evolution psychology
is false it's pseudoscience to say that
evolutionary psychology is pseudoscience
is like saying chemistry is
pseudoscience
there is no other game in town if you
believe that the human mind
evolved through material processes it's
not god who put it
there is no other game in town right so
to come back to the earlier wikipedia
point so one of the things that i
i'm trying to do here is to if you like
counter the most common criticism of
evolutionary psychology
that comes from fellow academics and
usually it is that evolutionary
psychology
is just a bunch of fanciful just so
storytelling right so i sit around
i put on my sexy barry white music i i'm
smoking a
pipe sipping some cognac and i just come
up with some [ __ ] quantification as
to why men
and as i showed you a few minutes ago no
when i want to prove to you that toy
preferences
are sex specific for an evolutionary
reason i actually go through
incredible length to do so much more so
than other sciences
so in my attempt to thwart this
i thought well if i can get more people
to think
along the ways of gnomological networks
and start building these
like a wisdom of the crowd where we can
build together
so if you want to go see what is the
current state of cumulative evidence
to prove that men have a preference for
the hourglass figure
you can go to that wikipedia of normal
logical networks and see it
does that give you a good feel i love
that i think james lindsay is trying to
create something
similar right but less than the
scientific side and
more kind of in the rhetoric side oh i
didn't know that yeah
he's got like 300 different definitions
of
so he's trying to provide a it would be
brilliant for you to reach out to right
so here's the question it's supposed to
be further down i'm supposed to ask you
this later on but i'm going to ask you
it now
um this comes from seeing douglas murray
live he's been on the show and he
went to go see him speak a live event
for the spectator
um and then he said something that stuck
with me which is a line he's used before
which is
uh when the barbarians are at the gates
we'll be debating about what gender they
are um yes i've heard that quote before
yes um
and that that married with a quote that
all of the listeners will be familiar
with which is
that the greatest minds of our era have
been
spent have spent their time working out
how to get people to click on ads
now my concern is i've got someone
like you multi-disciplinary polymath
james lindsey phd in pure mathematics
i don't want the brightest minds of our
time
to be taken up i don't want this in the
nicest way possible i wish that you
hadn't had to write this book
yes um what are you bored
of talking about social justice you know
fantastic question more than bored i'm
indignant
so oftentimes the most one of the most
indignant people i know yeah i love it
and
but and sometimes people say oh you know
but when i meet you or i see you
you seem like such a affable warm and
friendly
it's because they mistake my very
punchy my very at times acerbic wit and
sarcasm
as you know i'm this mean guy i'm i'm
exactly the opposite i'm the
the truly the warmest friendliest guy
but i'm
indignant i'm i'm angry for exactly the
reasons that you're saying
i'm angry that hundreds of thousands of
students in a world with
limited resources and limited time
instead of studying
many wonderful things and by the way i
don't believe that you could only
you should only be studying in
university you know medicine or
law or business or the natural sciences
you could study the social sciences very
seriously
you could study the humanities very
seriously you could study literature
very seriously but there's always a
commitment to a common discourse
to a commitment to reason irrespective
of whether it's in the humanities the
social sciences or natural sciences
but what i see in the universities it's
a minority but it's certainly a
powerful minority they they ruined the
lives of
thousands of students let alone the bank
accounts of their parents
who are spending 70 80 90 000
for somebody to take queering
architecture
and feminist glaciology that angers me
why
and this by the way goes to chapter one
of my of the parasitic mind because
i want to explain exactly why i'm
indignant and
and i argue that there are really two
life
ideals that drive who i am
one is truth and the second one is
freedom and i give examples from many
different
areas of my life not just my academic
life so let's take for example freedom
okay so freedom could be you know
freedom of speech right i'm a champion
of freedom of speech
but when i used to be a competitive
soccer player i played
the the playmaker role the number 10
role where i just kind of float around
whenever i had a coach who would put
restrictions on me you're playing today
more
on in left midfield and you have to
track back and cover somebody
suddenly my brain would explode because
you were removing
what i consider to be my greatest asset
which was
to kind of look for spaces to freely
roam around
looking for those opportunities right so
freedom is something that
constantly comes up in my life whether
it was when i was a soccer player
when i'm deciding which topics to pursue
as a scientific project so for example
the reason why i'm a polymath is because
i could never accept
that i'm at a business school therefore
i should only publish in these types of
journals
that suffocates me the playmaker of
academia
exactly right so because of these two
driving goals of freedom and truth
i see the world around me through very
pure lenses
so then when i see all what i call
intellectual terrorists
so the the post-modernists are right 9
11
they flew planes onto buildings while
the intellectual terrorists they fly
planes of [ __ ]
onto our edifices of reason right that
angers me why
because i come from civil war i come
from chaos
i come from tribalism i come from
identity politics
and now 40 years after leaving this
garbage in lebanon
i now see it taking foot in academia so
yes i wish i didn't have to do it
but to the extent that you see me being
punchy on social media
it comes from indignation not from
meanness yeah
again i don't have a problem with the
way that you deliver things i think you
and talib
and james lindsay and is that the thing
is that
the background that you and talib both
have because there is definitely some
similarities in the way that you deliver
your
discourse online yeah that's a another
great question uh
i think nasim and i are very good
friends for several reasons
one of which at least if i can speak for
him
in terms of you know i always joke that
nassim thinks 99 of humanity
are useless cretins that should be you
know killed
because they're imbeciles beyond
redemption and that i am
one of the few who makes it into his
you're in the cut you're in the one
percent i'm
really in like i i think i think getting
the approval of nasim might be bigger
than a nobel prize
right i mean i say that slightly
facetiously but i think the reason for
that
is because he appreciates in me that i
am
a costly signaling guy meaning that i
walk the walk
i don't give a [ __ ] in the game right so
because of that he respects that and i
also respect that in him
so partly because of our similar
personhood when it comes to that
combativeness
maybe partly because of the middle
eastern thing when you are my friend
i will die for you right so and i won't
get into specifics but i've
i could tell you that when it came to at
certain points
him defending me for something he was
willing to blow up the world
to come in my defense now for many
people we
so for example i have other friends who
naseem despises
and they will say to me they can't
understand why i would be friends with
him right
because they see him as this vile nasty
but the reality is that if you're in his
corner
he's much more likely to fight and die
for you in the trenches
than those highfalutin bullshitters who
would turn away
when you're screaming for help and
pretend that they didn't hear you so i
think because of that trait
uh we're simpatico on that dimension
fair weather friends man no one needs
any of them
exactly why is it the west where these
ideas
are proliferating surely living
standards being high
should give people less to complain
about not
so there are several reasons for that i
mean some of it comes from the frankfurt
school that kind of
kicked off some of this [ __ ] stuff
uh some of it is that
you know if i am suffering every day not
knowing if i'm gonna get my
caloric minimal caloric you know food
for the day
i don't have time to pontificate about
feminist glaciology
so in a sense it is a measure
of the decadence of the west right it's
kind of the caligula effect right
when rome becomes too uh you know imbued
with all of this
hedonic pursuits it kind of
self-implodes so i think there's a
similar thing here where
instead of you know feasting at the
buffet of
gluttony the actual food where we're
feasting at the gluttony of [ __ ]
ideas
because in a sense it demonstrates how
well we have it in the west right
but by the way that's another thing that
really pisses me off because the people
who
the people at wellesley college who are
complaining that they were misgendered
should have lived tuesday morning at 10
o'clock in the morning
of my childhood in lebanon where i
didn't know at 10 o'clock whether at 10
05
my head would still be connected to the
rest of my body
maybe that's another source of
indignation right when you're constantly
whining
when you simply don't know what else
there is in the world right
that is frustrating to those who have
lived that right so
ayan hershey ali do you know who that is
yeah
so ayan hershey ali should be someone
that people
seriously listen to because she's lived
islam
and yet she is a you know hitler bigot
who is an islamophobe i mean
if a black woman from somalia who is an
ex-muslim
is somebody that doesn't carry the right
identity markers
to speak about islam then we're lost
right so i think that's another reason
of my indignation and that is that
boy are you sheltered when you complain
about the things that you do in the west
it's interesting this i've been playing
with this all year
the idea that in the absence of a real
crisis we create our own
and in the presence of a real crisis we
reset our values it's like this abundant
scarcity paradigm
also is mapped onto uh the abstraction
and the realism of the problems that we
have and i think
very much as you said there it's a
maslow's hierarchy of needs thing
like no one's having an existential
crisis if you don't know where your next
food's coming from
you might be worried about where the
next meal is coming from but you're not
that fussed about whether or not your
social network's quite right or whether
you've actualized and you just want to
be warm be
fed and go to sleep in somewhere safe so
i man i i totally agree
um what role does ridicule play
in defending the public from these ideas
well i have a whole section in the
parasitic mind on the power of satire
right is this sorry is this from an
evolutionary perspective as well because
i'd love to hear i'd love to hear how
this maps onto that
uh so i don't in in the in the section
in the parasitic mind i don't
specifically link it to an evolutionary
underpinning
although off the top of my head since
you asked
and this is not specific to satire but
certainly
humor has been studied from an
evolutionary perspective then i'll come
back to satire in particular
humor has been studied in the following
way from an evolutionary perspective it
is a
honest signal of your intelligence
right so so when women constantly say
they are
attracted to a funny guy but you don't
you sell them here
guys saying you know she's gorgeous with
the most beautiful hourglass figure but
if she's not funny
there's no sex for you lately she just
doesn't make me laugh yeah she just
doesn't make me laugh but my god what a
beautiful behind she has but too bad
because she's not going to get any of me
because she doesn't make me laugh right
so but the reason why women insist on on
uh
funny guys is because usually it is a
very good correlate of intelligence
right it's very hard to be witty
sardonically witty to be sarcastic at
the right delivery
if you're a you know babbling fool right
you have to have a very sharp
mind to be able to very quickly identify
this thing so now coming back to satire
i think
satire so the the the the expression i
like to use is
properly activated satire is like the
surgeon's scalpel cutting through
warm butter right because it cuts to the
heart
of the the stuff right so for example
i'll give you one quick
example that i just started recently so
right now
on on social media i'm not sure if
you've seen it or not i know what you're
going to say yeah it's great
what is it is it where you've been
suggesting
the most outrageous books that you can
for people to read and then
saying if you don't read this then
you're a bigot i i i have done that
thank you for noticing that no but now
oh there's different weapons right
there's different things
i i activate the satire so now if
anybody sends me any compliments and
thank i receive
a million of those on social media i
will always state
that i need to know what your skin u is
before either accepting the compliment
or not
if you don't have 50 plus people of
color
you then i'm sorry but i reject your
compliment because i'm trying to
decolonize my twitter feed right so
what i've done is i've taken literal
things that these morons say
and i've just taken them to the extreme
people say
how come you never get into trouble i
mean no one
i mean the most irreverent person
that you could think of doesn't weigh in
one
percent of what i do and yet knock on
wood
i'm still not cancelled well i think
it's because i found
naturally by instinct the the wormhole
of how to tackle these issues right so
for example
it's very hard to pin me because when i
say something sarcastically
you could technically not know whether
what i'm saying is right
so if you come at me i say what are you
talking about bullshitter
i am totally decolonizing my twitter
feed
i don't want to receive compliments from
from you know people that suffer from
being white if they disgust
you get it yeah so what happens is i am
pointing the mirror i'm taking the exact
semantic structure of your argument and
i'm laughing i'm i'm
mocking it into oblivion right that's
why i survive because
now but that's exactly why dictators
throughout history and i point to many
different of these guys
have despised the satirists because the
the guy who is a
a very powerful satirist is a lot more
threatening
to the dictator than the guys with the
big muscles the guy with the sharp
tongue
is the guy you really want to kill i
would i mean
online is a perfect example i would much
less like andrew doyle
or zooby to come after me than nassim
and the reason for that is there's going
to be so much
social embarrassment because they're
going to find a thing that i did or that
i said
and they're gonna make me feel so dumb
and this is the
the particular modus operandi of
yourself uh andrew doyle specifically
and
zubi's very famous video where he did
the deadlift record
it's utilizing the weaponry the semantic
weaponry against people who are
weaponizing it against you
um but yeah thinking about the satire
thing for yourself
i don't know whether you've played you
almost certainly won't have done but
call of duty warzone is super popular at
the moment and my housemate plays it
and you get to choose like a preference
of a loadout
of your different weapons and you can
have like this automatic rifle and this
knife and this gun or whatever
and it definitely feels like satire is
like the go-to
primary weapon for you absolutely it's
like that's the one that you get that's
the first gun that you pick up and then
maybe there'll be a little bit of this
and then a little bit of that and
there's quote tweeting quite a bit
beca specifically because on
social media i don't have the
platform to build geonomological
networks of cumulative evidence right
so i have to take the sharp surgeon's
scalpel
and very quickly right so for example i
say you know it disgusts me
when a noble faith that is responsible
for 36 000
deaths 36 000 terror attacks since 9 11
alone in 70 countries when people
associate that faith
to violence that's disgusting that's
phobic
well come at me i'm being truthful i'm
not being sarcastic
i mean you only have 36 000 data points
from seven countries varying across
every ethnic racial economic system
linguistic system
if only there was a way to identify a
common thread across these well
how could you attack me right because
you lit right
so by by providing you with the packets
of information
in a way that is enrobed in sarcasm
in sardonic wit in satire it almost
makes it now the difficulty though is
it's hard to kind of teach a seminar on
this right because
it's hard to say please come to
professor sad sardonic wit seminar
so that you can castrate the morons
right
because in a sense there are certain
rules that you can use in building your
satirical arguments
but it's also instinctual so some people
just have it right
for example i don't believe that
charisma is something that you can teach
in leadership class right you're either
charismatic
or not right now you could within
certain
you know little plus minus epsilon
can teach somebody to be a slightly
better orator so even martin luther king
wasn't as good an orator you know early
in his career as
later in his career but he had to start
off with the stuff
which someone else doesn't so i've
always kind of questioned
is there a way for me to truly have a
how-to playbook of satire
i don't know what do you think do you
think it's possible to teach i'm
currently reading robert ploman's book
about about blueprint about genetics and
increasingly i'm no realizing
just how restricted we are with all of
our characteristics
the classic like nba i'm not six foot
six i can't play in the nba
example the same thing goes for this
there are certain immutable truths and
capacities and restrictions that you
have
some of them are visible some of them
are invisible and the invisible
ones you know not everyone's built to be
a podcaster i'm shy to art
like i'm really really i have that still
the drawing skills i had when i was
about five years old
um i'm the exact same way fantastic well
we're birds of a feather
right we've done your book is fantastic
it will be linked in the show notes
below and that is
that's that i'm stopping now the talk
about social justice and i want to
utilize you for the next 20 minutes on
some other good topics
sure go for it who do you think will win
the us election
oh wow what a great question uh
i warned you i warned you that we were
out of the safe woods and we're into
this i mean the only reason i'm hesitant
is because i genuinely don't have a good
sense
uh i could tell you who i'd liked to who
i'd like
to say that's not the question that i
asked god i'm still gonna go with
trump will win would you have said that
in april
uh so at the start of the so before
kovid i would have said
it's 95 sure that he would win with
kovid and all of the imbeciles that now
say well look
the deaths it's trump right this is like
your aunt got diabetes during trump well
there's really only one conclusion
it must be that trump caused her
diabetes because bro it's during his
presidency
right an amazonian fraud just died in
the amazon
it is during trump's presidency so how
could you not see the link [ __ ] right
so because most people have the
cognitive abilities of a newborn pigeon
they are regrettably all placing the
blame on trump
so now um i think it's almost a toss up
i think that the polls
still show biden as winning for similar
reasons as to what happened with hillary
clinton
when it comes down to finally going to
the booths
i still think trump will win if that
happens with the last few months
of very very vehement manipulation by
press
and also such compromise by a lot of the
people who are weaponizing
um movements of goodwill for a political
agenda
on in all different manners by any means
it was a consequentialist
uh outcome that you were talking about
earlier on it's like by any means if we
get him out of office if the orange man
[ __ ] off yeah it's worth it if he gets
voted back in
that is the kitchen sink's been thrown
out the cat's gone at them
you know somewhat someone's pooed in the
hand
they've had a crack at that that is
everything they've thrown at him
and it still hasn't worked yeah uh so
you're saying what would happen if he
were to wait
i just think that if it happens and he
he does win
after every weapon under the sun that
has been picked out by mainstream media
and individuals and
movement groups and stuff like that i
think it's a stark
message about just how wrong
the democrat messaging the left
messaging generally is at the moment and
how much it doesn't resonate with
the normal people not the people that
live on twitter exactly
uh look uh do you want me to talk a bit
about why
a lot of people have a hard time but you
know professor i look up to you how
could you support a maniac like trump
first of all there's a difference
between the positions that i take
and supporting trump right i always say
that i don't have posters of trump which
my wife
and i use in the bedroom as foreplay
right it's so it's
so the fact that i explain why trump is
a very
viable option doesn't mean that i'm a
pro-trump guy i understand that he's
brash and he's vulgar and he's
non-presidential
but as i explained recently in a clip a
sad truth clip
there's an expression that i that that i
bring from from arabic
that basically says to get drunk by
smelling
the cork of the wine bottle right what
is that in arabic please
uh uh means like the raisins but you can
also
apply it for the cork okay so so here's
the here's the cork right
so i could either drink the wine to get
drunk
or i could just go i'm already drunk
now do you understand the the analogy
here that that means that
it takes very little to get me drunk
because i'm a [ __ ] because i'm a
lightweight right
so here's what most people do including
some of my very highfalutin
highbrow cerebral friends okay
trump is vulgar he
speaks in a brash way he's cantankerous
he's brazenly boastful
therefore he attacks my sense of
aesthetics
this is what i call an aesthetic injury
right
but now look you see i'm getting drunk
you see
on the other hand obama he's lanky
he's tall he's majestic he's got a
radiant smile
i'm getting more drunk by the second you
see i'm getting a bit wobbly right
he's got a millefluous voice oh my god
i'm getting drunk
he's presidential now what obama says
is utter garbage it's rehearsed
platitudinous vacuous [ __ ]
okay if anything the semantics of what
trump might say
might actually be much more substantive
but trump is
vulgar and disgusting he repulses me
therefore he is a monster right this is
why in chapter 2
of the parasitic mind i have a section
the chapter is about
feeling versus thinking it is wrong to
pit these two systems against one
another
humans are both a thinking animal and a
feeling animal
the problem is when you activate the
wrong system
at the wrong moment right when i'm
walking down an alley
and i see four young men loitering in
the alley and my heart starts racing
and i start getting kind of an anxiety
thing so my affective system is kicking
in
it makes perfect sense i've evolved to
have that fear response
in that case having my affective system
kick in
makes perfect sense on the other hand if
i'm trying to do well on a
calculus exam my affective system is not
as good to activate as my cognitive
system
so when it comes to choosing my
presidents using
my affective system as the key driver he
disgusts me
he's repulsive he's no he's yes he is
that
but what's the content he supports
freedom of speech
the left doesn't i've already have
enough to support him
the fact that he is a brazen narcissist
i couldn't give a [ __ ]
obama was as much of a narcissist but i
didn't succumb
to the the cork because i see through
his [ __ ]
you get what i'm saying and i think
regrettably most of my
highfalutin colleagues are unable to see
this because
they come from a rarified world where
you
speak i can speak as fancily and
probably ten times more fancy than all
of them combined
but i can also say [ __ ] right and
that
that that's why i say i'm the professor
of the people so i can connect
with trump on his level i get what he's
doing
he's a buffoon in that in a style sense
but the content of what he says he is
against open immigration
he cares more about radical islam so how
could you have one of my friends you
probably can guess who he is
who has historically built his career
criticizing islam
but then when it came to supporting
trump or hillary clinton
he supported hillary clinton who is the
one who would have opened the door
to the whole so how do you reconcile
this well
as he tells me but he disgusts me
as someone who spent an awful lot of
time trying to uh
separate himself from his emotions that
is not the answer
that he should have given it's it's so
interesting man especially as a brit i
don't have a dog in this fight i mean i
i don't want the world to break
um but the uh i have no preference
and yet i i can totally see how people
get
confused by that but the the bottom line
for me is that
yeah trump is um uncouth
and he's simple in a way
but that simpleness belies honesty
and yes i think that's a big part of why
people didn't vote for hillary
that they were sick of the bare-faced
actually no sorry they were they were
sick of the very manipulative
very malicious cleverly constructed lies
like
they'll take the uncomfortable brash
glitzy covered in gold and stardust
sort of ugly truth over a platitude that
they know will never materialize
100 and linking back to what you just
said to naseem and i
our friendship we're both direct talkers
right
we're both no bs therefore we can
see what trump is it's not as though
we're simpletons who don't understand
that he's got certain
qualities yeah yeah exactly but it's
that
i i don't want to speak for nasima so
i'll speak for myself his authenticity
is something that i greatly value i
prefer
a bull in a china shop that is uncouth
as you said who is vulgar
rather than the platitudinous radiant
smile of obama you know why he's stunned
exactly you know what he's done and i
have a heart attack before before just
i have a hard time understanding why
my otherwise very bright colleagues
don't see that right i'm me and you are
cut from the same cloth
when it comes to that i think that
there's maybe a little bit of uh
grumpiness being used as a um
appropriate measuring tool there the
fact that if you have
not a short fuse but a short tolerance
for
[ __ ] that you actually are able to
kind of cut through at least some of the
sort of rhetoric that's been pushed
recently um
we've been talking a lot recently about
uh the gender sex gap
on this podcast um how much do you think
that the shifts in sexual norms and
sexual marketplace like
less monogamy and tinder and gender
imbalance on campuses and in cells and
so on
has contributed to the current social
unrest among young people
any specific area of society
i mean the fact that we're so ready to
riot
and loot and also be very v
sort of um vociferous online when we
don't have anything to back it up
um it just seems like there's a lot of
unrest among young people is it the fact
that they're not getting
laid well i i don't know if i can
tie the in-cell phenomenon to the you
know the chaos that we see
i think it's a bit of a i like to be
very tight i'd like to have my
entomological network
exactly tight before i pronounce them
but i can certainly tell you that
evolutionary speaking we do
know that societies that
have many men twiddling their thumbs
in frustrated celibacy is not the recipe
for a stable society right so for
example if you look around the world
across cultures
about 85 percent of cultures
have either condoned or accepted or had
some form
of polygyny belligerenty means one man
multiple women
uh about 15 so the rest of the
pie is monogamy and a very very very
small percentage way less than one
percent
is polyandry one woman with many men now
in those cases
the most famous example of that is
called a fraternal
tibetan polyandry in those cases
it's a tibetan system where one woman
is shared by multiple men but the
multiple men
are brothers in other words that's so
[ __ ] up but but now let me explain the
evolutionary reason for that
for whatever reason we have to get into
the details you don't want to have a
whole bunch of men for example
you don't want only the eldest to have
access sexual access
but then all the younger brothers to be
twiddling their sons that's not going to
read to a
stable society so the next best thing is
to have
multiple men share a woman but they're
brothers because then in that case
if the the best thing is for me to
extend my genes directly through
direct reproductive fitness i am sure
that it is my child
the next best thing is if the woman that
i'm sharing
has a child let it at least be someone
who is genetically related to 50
of my genes or whatever exactly that i
can increase my fitness
indirectly through kin selection so
so i can't answer the incel versus chaos
but i can certainly tell you that a lot
of evolutionists have thought about
what happens to societies when you get a
lot of sexually frustrated men and it's
never a good thing
okay so evolutionary science would it
say sexual inequality
is as powerful of an explanation for
rage as economic inequality say
well depends what you mean by sexual
inequality i mean
this you see what i mean yeah exactly
there are different currencies you could
use right so
uh but speaking of the gender gap issues
this may or may not be where you want to
go but uh
one of the things that we talk about in
universities is something that i've uh
i mean humorously but truthfully
referred to as the die religion
diversity
inclusion and equity right so i
reorganize the the letter so that it's
die
because it's literally the death of
meritocracy is the death of common sense
right
now n universities my universities and
every other university
it's now being run by the daisars right
so professorships are granted
not based on the merit of your cv
but it is based on whether you have the
right identity markers
one of which since we're talking about
gender gap and so on one of which is
you know some professorships you are
officially not allowed to apply
unless you are a woman or you
self-identify as a woman
that's not satire this is literally true
don't apply right it's well first of all
you wonder how is that not illegal
but now here's the here's the little rub
a hundred years ago we had institutional
you know sexism whereby women were
denied
equal access to education in which case
that was wrong
and we've corrected it now today here is
the data
that i'd like to report to your viewers
in the us if you take
five races so black white hispanic
uh you know native american i can't
remember the fifth one
so across five races and four
levels of education so in the u.s you
have what's called an associate's degree
which is half a bachelor's then you have
a bachelor's degree
then you have masters then you have
doctoral so you have five races
by four educational levels so there are
20 cells
guess how many of the cells do
women outnumber men you follow the
question
so there are 20 cells how many of those
cells
okay let's do it the other way actually
how many of the cells do men
out number women i just i had my answer
right now you've flipped it and said
um i would say that
women will outnumber men
i think women outnumber men in in the 20
cells
you're exactly correct i guess maybe i
set it up in such a way that you were
going to go this way
now if it were that we need programs
to protect women in university it should
be
what it was a hundred years ago which is
if we took this exact same
data matrix 20 out of the 20 cells it
would be men
outnumbering women and we need to
redress that
well today not 100 years ago
across every race and every educational
level
women outnumber men so what is the
logical conclusion of what we should do
we need more programs to protect women
because brah misogyny
okay so this is what an idea pathogen
does to your brains
it says i don't give a [ __ ] about this
racist
thing called data and facts and science
and numbers
i care about a victimhood narrative and
there is no amount of evidence that you
could give me
that you can deny the fact that women
are afraid to walk on campus
because of daily gang grapes right so
now that doesn't mean that i don't
support by the way i was asked to
appear at a business school luncheon or
whatever
to give a talk on how i am a better ally
to women
guess how that conversation went uh i
said
no i'm not an ally to women i'm an ally
to all
individuals i have been an ally to women
i have been an ally to men i have been
to ally to people who are purple who are
white who are fat who are short
i judge people based on the merits of
who they are
so then i said but i'm willing to come
and talk about evolutionary based sex
differences
oh let us get back to you professor that
they never got back to you i know for a
fact
but they got back and said sorry we're
going another direction
right so why should i support that
victimhood narrative
i mean the my dean who's a fantastic uh
person is a woman the the the uh the
associate dean of research
is a woman the head of my department
is a woman some of the recent research
professorships are
all women so guess what let's find a way
to be
better allies to women that makes no
sense right so
how about we stop with the victimhood
narrative drop all this die religion
[ __ ]
and go back to an ethos of individual
dignity
that's a cervix privilege for you man
honestly
it's um one thing i think it was goethe
that talks about
how society vacillates between different
extremes
and it moves between them and it kind of
seems like
that's the case but in his argument he
talked about that vacillation then
the the frequency starts to dial down
over time and you
reach a center a balance point what's
your prediction for the future of crazy
social justice ideas are we on
where are we on the trend curve are we
is the roller coaster still going up or
i think we're still going up but here's
some good news
if i can leave the audience with some
optimism that would be
wonderful i think it would take
very very little for the whole thing to
crash
in other words it it's it to use the
the term of nasim kalib social justice
warrior [ __ ]
is fragile it's not anti-fragile if
you're
able to truly shock the system then the
whole thing will collapse now
what's what what is the concrete what
does it mean concretely to shock the
system
the silent majority hates the stuff
okay i know this because i receive
a million emails a day from all
professors
who are too afraid to speak and they say
thank you you're my only uh ticket to
sanity
so i know that 99 of people
are against this stuff except that each
of the 99
is too afraid to speak up so it is left
on three
four five people to carry the burden for
everyone else
the day that people find
their testicles whether they're males or
female and actually
activate their testicular fortitude and
speak out and say
enough of this my seven-year-old child
is not learning white fragility in class
it's not going to happen and if
everybody does that
the whole thing will go away if not then
your vacillation that you spoke of
will instead of it being done by next
tuesday it will take another 30 years
of wasted talent wasted money uh
tuitions and so on
wow final question is a request
it's to a request to improve your
twitter feed actually i know that you
you
have a lot of different things but this
is my sort of personal
input um would more shirtless photos be
an option
in my current state i think it would be
a crime against humanity to have a
shirtless photo my 1985
version is what is known as godlike so
if you want more photos of 1985
i think it's a benefit to society if you
want of me right
now i think i should be arrested if you
considered because bella thorne
recently broke the single day record for
only funds
have you considered doing a godzad only
funds
and you could maybe have like some
training footage of nassim on there as
well because he likes to deadlift
it's funny you say this because one of
the things that's been frustrating for
me
but i haven't given it much thought is
that i haven't been able to grow my
patreon support
and you know that when people you know
give you support and so on because i do
spend
a tremendous amount of effort take great
risk to do this and one should be
remunerated
or at least have an insurance policy uh
and i think one of the reasons i haven't
been able to do it is because i don't
um have the tier the tier reward system
right it's just i appeal to people's
decency hey you consume my content why
don't you donate
that i don't think that works so maybe
at the hundred dollars or more there
should be
shirtless option in which case maybe
that's something absolutely
if you want that comment below uh with
we want to see you shirtless please god
and um we'll see if we can make it
happen look link
to the parasitic mind will be linked in
the show notes below anything else that
people should check out where else do
you want them to go
uh they can go and you know sign up to
my twitter feed
uh at gatsad g-a-d-s-a-a-d i
a few months ago i started a new uh
personal website with what everything
has on it
gotsad.com you can go check it out i've
got my podcast which i started recently
i've had my youtube channel for many
years but people kept saying well we
don't want just a youtube channel we
want to be able to download things
and so you can go check me out on my
podcast i'm all over the place i'm hard
to miss
i love it man thank you so much for your
time this was very very much worth the
wait
pleasure thank you for having me
you